KAMALA KHAN
How did she convince everyone
that she's good?
Good is not a thing you are, Kamala.
It is a thing you do.
KAMALA KHAN
I know dressing up
as Captain Marvel is weird.
I spend too much time in fantasy land.
Cool. Is this Nani's?
MUNEEBA KHAN
That is just junk.
♪♪
KAMALA KHAN
Whoa.
BRUNO CARRELLI
What does it feel like?
KAMALA KHAN
Like an idea come to life.
Everything's changing really fast.
YUSUF KHAN
If you save one life...
...you save the world.
♪♪
BRUNO CARRELLI
Are you sure that we can keep that on?
- It's an homage.
- That's a lawsuit.
KAMALA KHAN
Great. Then I'll meet Captain Marvel
in court and we'll be the
first case in the American Judiciary
to hug it out.